نحن في منطقتنايكان في العاصمه الالمانيه
برلين هنا تركز كبير لمن هم من اصول
مهاجره والترقب هنا ايضا كبير لمشروع
قانون الجنسيه الجديد الذي تعملوا عليه
الحكومه والذي سيقصر مهله التقدم للحصول
على جوازنا الماني من ثمان سنوات الى خمس
سنوات ويسمح بتعدد الجنسيه ولكن المشروع
لا يحظى بتاييد اكبر حزب معرض احد
المسؤولين في هذا الحزب الحزب المسيح
الديمقراطي والذي يعمل في بلديه كلب يشرح
لنا اسباب الوقوف في حزب ماركه العائقا
امام تطوير القانون الجنسيه طوال عقد ونصف
من وجوده في السلطه
ولكن يجب ان تكون هناك شروط واضحه النظام
صعب عندما يكون الاشخاص يتلقون اعانه
اجتماعيه من المهم جدا ان يعود الى العمل
اولا لان لدي مخاوف جديه من جره الى انظمه
الاجتماعيه ويبدو ان تعديلات الحكومه لن
تاخذ هذا بعين الاعتبار
بانه سيجذب اليها المزيد من المهاجرين
الذين تحتاجهم مثل الاطباء لملئ عشرات
الالاف من الوظائف الشاغره في البلاد
الدكتور احمد القادم من مصر تقدم باوراقه
للحصول على جواز الالماني ولكنه يامل ان
يقرر قانون الجديد قريبا او على الاقل
نقطه واحده محدده في هذا القانون
انا لازم احتفظ بالجنسيه المصريه انا
هافضل طول عمره مصر الباسبور ده هي وثيقه
سفر مش اكثر ولا اقل يعني مش عايز يتنزل
على الجنسيه المصريه الالمانيه على قد ما
انا الجنسيه المصريه
ولكنها من دون شك اعترافنا بان المانيا لم
تعد قادره على اخفائي ان هبتت فعلا دوله
مهاجرين رغب بهنام العربيه